♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WRAPPER KANYE WEST
HAS BEEN BACK ON TWITTER FOR
LESS THAN TWO WEEKS AND HE IS
ALREADY BROUGHT THIS SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANY TO ITS KNEES.
IN AN EPIC FOUR DAY RAMPAGE
THROUGH CYBERSPACE, HE SHARED
VIDEOS BY SCOTT ADAMS POSTING A
PHOTOGRAPH OF HIMSELF IN A MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT AND
EARNED TWO RETWEETS FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
PROGRESSIVES ARE ALMOST
UNCONSCIOUS WITH RAGE.
"ROLLING STONE" MAGAZINE CALLS
WEST'S TWEETS OR REAL THREAT.
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST MARK STEYN
KNOWS IT'S A THREAT.
WHAT ARE HIS TWEETS A THREAT TO?
>> THERE A THREAT TO THE
LOCKSTEP OF POPULAR CULTURE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
TO SOME EXTENT, I'M NOT
UNSYMPATHETIC TO THAT.
SOME PEOPLE ARE MOCKING US
CONSERVATIVES BECAUSE WHEN SOME
BEATNIKS DIG LIKE KANYE WEST
COME ON, WE ALL GET SO EXCITED.
HE'S GIVING US THE EYE.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT -- I
REMEMBER IN THE 2000 ELECTION
GOING TO THE REPUBLICAN
CONVENTION AND BEING GIVEN THE
FOLDER TO SHOW WHICH CELEBRITIES
FOLDER TO SHOW WHICH CELEBRITIE
CELEBRITIES -- IT WAS A
DETECTIVE PIECE OF PAPER WITH
TWO NAMES ON ONE SIDE.
IT WAS PAT BOONE AND ONE OF THE
OAK RIDGE BOYS.
SEVEN OF THEM ARE DEMOCRATS
THERE WAS SOMETHING TERRIBLY
REFRESHING AND HAVING NO
PURCHASE ON POP CULTURE.
THE FACT IS, WE ARE NOT REALLY
EXCITED.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH THE EXCITEMENT
FROM OUR END.
IT'S THE FACT THAT KANYE IS A
SICK OF BEING TOLD WHAT TO THINK
SICK OF BEING TOLD WHAT TO THIN
THINK.
THE CELEBRITY SUPPORTERS ARE
GETTING SMALLER AND SMALLER AND
SMALLER.
AND A SELF-RESPECTING MAN LIKE
THIS GUY IS, HE DOESN'T WANT TO
BE PUT IN THAT BOX.
HE WANTS TO BUST OUT OF THAT BOX
HE WANTS TO BUST OUT OF THAT BO
BOX.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU SAYING ART
IS NOT THE SAME THING AS
CONFORMITY?
>> I AM.
ODDLY ENOUGH, IT'S STRANGE
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING ON ABOUT HOW
TRANSGRESSIVE WE ARE.
WE NEED TRANSGRESSIVE ARTISTS
AND THEN THEY DEMAND THAT ALL OF
THE ARTISTS IMPROVE THE IDEOLOGY
THE ARTISTS IMPROVE THE IDEOLOG
IDEOLOGY.
IN A WAY, IT'S OBVIOUS
CORRECTION.
TRUMP IS A SHOWBIZ FIGURE.
HE DID BEAUTY PAGEANTS AND A
REALITY SHOW.
HE'S ON THE REGIS PHILBIN
CHRISTMAS ALBUM FIRING BLITZEN
AND HIRING THE RUDOLPH THE RED
NOSE REINDEER.
THE MAN IS ON THE CHRISTMAS
ALBUM.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT FROM
KANYE'S POINT OF VIEW, HE WALKS
INTO A ROOM AND THERE IS
CHUCK SCHUMER AND THERE IS
ELIZABETH WARREN AND ANY OTHER
CORNER IS DONALD TRUMP, WHO IS
HE GOING TO GO AND TALK TO A
QUESTION MARK HE'S GOING TO TALK